[Music]
ray it is truly
my honor to be welcoming you into
conversation
here for wharton people analytics i'm
gonna dig
right in with uh what i think you're
best known for and i think this is what
we should talk about
today which is um how we can use
feedback how we can get real feedback
um in real time from other people um
i want to start with how you came to
this i think it's a
i don't know epiphany realization life
philosophy um
would you share a little bit about
radical transparency and
and where you came upon it um in 1982
i made you know like a terrible mistake
in the markets
uh crashed um you know very very painful
mistake
and i reflected on it and then i started
to realize
that uh
the success that i could have came from
going beyond what i had in my head and
what i
personally knew and that
i wanted every i worried about being
wrong
and i wanted to continue to be audacious
and go for my goals but
i wanted others to stress test me and to
be challenged so i didn't care about
where being right
came from i just wanted to be right and
make the best decisions and so
that painful mistake um
had a big effect on me so anyway what
what i really learned about
was um let's say
pain plus reflection equals progress
so if radical transparency is almost a
surefire way
to learn from pain to to to continue to
develop no matter
how you um already how well you already
do something then why is it
i think relatively uncommon to embrace a
kind of like i want to know
what everyone else truly thinks about me
so we think about disagreement what
disagreement could be right
if two people are disagreeing um
somebody's
probably wrong and how do you know that
person isn't you
how do you know you're not the wrong one
so logically you would have curiosity
that would be the thing why is it and
how do we resolve it so i make sure i'm
right
but yet you have this experience instead
where
it's like an attack however all of this
can be changed i found that we
you know we have our culture and we have
a culture like this
and if people um realize that that's
really good for them
that self understanding the
understanding of others and how it works
together and getting at the right answer
that kind of thing and they start to
realize that that is what makes them
successful
that experience in 1982 which gave me
you know the the fear and humility i
needed while still
going through forward to my audacious
goals
was something that um i realized others
could have
and if they start to realize from that
point on
we were successful from that point on
because of how we dealt with it
because it wasn't all in our heads
because we would deal with what was
truthful
and we would deal with our realities
well and
and by interacting well and then we
would have the meaningful
you know the meaningful um
work and meaningful relationships thing
is very very powerful
and then also um if you have
truthfulness
radical truthfulness and radical
transparency
then you can find out what's true
because if you're not truthful you won't
get at what's true
so that's not practical and then also
you build trust
and i was gonna ask you about that some
people listening to you might think like
wow like i
i think if everybody really tells each
other what they think and
you know some part of the time those are
negative or critical thoughts
like it's going to undermine trust my
sense is that at bridgewater and in your
experience it does exactly the opposite
that when you have
right because we know right we know if
somebody's being radically truthful with
us right particularly if it's framed
well so that you
explain to people you know look this is
just how i'm seeing it and i might be
wrong
and we should discuss it and we should
explore it how do we get at what's true
because if we can get at what's true
that's fundamental to making progress
and if we all have these hidden agendas
and those things in our head
that's going to stand in the way of
progress so let's talk about opinion
versus data it might seem like the
obvious solution to
not having on the whole picture wanting
to know what everybody else thinks as
you make your way through the jungle
to the other side it might seem like oh
well i'll just ask a couple of
people for their opinion tell me what
you think about opinion versus data
well um opinions are conclusions
i find that so many people start with
conclusions
i mean like who cares i don't care about
anybody's opinion
i care about how they got to their
opinion right
so and and and then different people
have different opinions so we have to
realize
um like you've seen personality profile
tests and so on
or just in any contact that if you ask
somebody to describe what's happening
and you you know it's like the seven
blind men and the elephant
they're all going to describe what's
happening in their own particular
way because that's the reality that's
their own perspective
which they can't get out of objective
right so not all opinions are equally
good
like some people may on some subjects
not have
earned the right to have an opinion you
know if you're going to pick a doctor
and you're you're going to say uh okay i
want three doctors
who are smart they're you know in other
words i have reasons to believe that i
want to hear their reasoning
and i want them to disagree with each
other because it's in that disagreement
that i can find the best answer
then at the end of the day you say what
are you going to do
but it's not because we're going to
start with random people
and having that and data is uh
has objectivity when you start to bring
in the data and you together
say let's look at the data let's look at
the evidence
so let's say you and i have a different
opinion on something okay that's fine
and then go on an investment for example
angela
angela or let's say on people or comment
i would rather be
disagreeing with you on people than an
investment but that's right right
right so that's right and i listen to
you because i would say wow you've got a
lot of experience
and then it is in the joy of the back
and forth
and if we can check it off and we can
sort of say we agree now
so we would say when we're looking at
data
how could we find out how could we be
scientific
like how do we have a testable
hypothesis right like not just sort of
a foregone conclusion which is in some
ways untestable
but like what are the assumptions what
are the assumptions or the data that
lead us to a certain
opinion or conclusion so so it sounds
like data is not just the plural of
opinion
that's very it is um part of the process
that leads one to opinion right it's the
input okay so let's actually turn to
personality assessments now
uh i recently learned that you have
created with
adam grant and and others uh um
a new personality assessment um i'd love
you to tell me more about that
well about 25 years ago i started to see
that
like so many people uh see things
differently
and then i learned okay there's this
test called myers-briggs
and i gave it to uh of
top managers in my in my company and
um and so they took it um and then i
read its output person by person and
in many cases i said wow i didn't
believe anybody thought that way
let's say the big picture thinker and
the detail thinker
the big picture thinker says oh and we
could do this and they're thinking
abstractly of the future and so on
the detail thinker who is more in the
now and here in the pr
practicalities would say to the your
head's in the clouds
you know kind of will you get grounded
and the
and the big picture said thinker says
you were tripping up on all these
details and so on don't you see the big
picture
and the truth is they need each other so
all of these different types of thinking
have a purpose
right but they are different types of
thinking you were telling me about like
you know these other personality
assessments that you were then exploring
after the myers-briggs um because i do
want to know
why you didn't just use one of the
off-the-shelf
personality assessments and um and and
what you've designed with principles you
uh well uh that's it yeah that's it
because
what i have i couldn't get all that i
needed in in one
i mean they would i think you know there
are just so many dimensions of a person
to a person and then uh they would all
give little
tech dimensions pictures and i wanted
the whole
better picture and i wanted to bring it
all together and i wanted what also the
things that i wanted to look for
and i could do this you know uh so why
not bring
the best of the best together and you
know have fun and
build that thing together and we did and
um so it's we've done all the beta
testing
you know and lots of people have taken
it and um
it's great and they they you took it so
we'll maybe chat about that
um but uh we've taken surveys and they
say
it's the best description of them so if
most accurate in in relationship to the
other ones
um and then we also made it um that
it would show relationships between
people
so in other words if one person takes it
and another person takes it they might
say okay here's my
my partner or a friend or whatever what
and they would put it together
and it will give them uh insights on
their relationships and then we're
building it out so that it can be used
uh in companies for forming teams you
know what does your team look like
what is your team's bias uh what might
you be missing
and all of that so um it's been great
so what is the i did take it by the way
and um
one of my i guess top uh traits was
orchestrator which i thought to be true
um i wonder what were the
characteristics that you maybe thought
were absent
in most inventories that um that you
included in principles u
i wanted to find as i found a
replacement for me at bridgewater i
wanted to find a certain type of person
a shaper so i wanted to find somebody
who could go from visualization to
actualization
and so then i gave the tests um to
uh you know people who were shapers i
knew i gave it to bill gates elon musk
um
reid hastings um
[Music]
you know a lot of people uh but also not
just in the
business world i gave it to um muhammad
yunus who won the nobel peace prize
for microfinance and social i gave it to
jeffrey canada hardline's children's
zone
but people who made this big
you know they could go from
visualization to actualization because i
wanted to
get the type of person i wanted to find
out there were different types of
persons or
personalities for different types of
roles and so on to fit them kind of
into the role not just to describe what
it was
um and so you know that that that was a
big dimension
um and it was great because i could get
a prototype
i found that um that these
shapers have an enormous amount in
common
i mean basically a comment what is more
what is a shaper like shaper is not
what i meant is somebody who has an
idea of visualization you know um
elon musk says you know we're gonna go
to space we can go to the moon
we gotta go to another planet or
something or a different visualization
and actually builds it out and you
decided to make this personality
assessment unlike
i believe all of the ones that you
mentioned you decided to make it free
and public and i was surprised by that
because i thought this was an internal
bridgewater
proprietary
i'm at a stage in my life what's my
purpose of my life
now my purp i'm 71 years old
the purpose of my life now is to pass
along the things that were good
help me that others can use
because i'm not going to be around you
know a limited amount of time
on my journey i learned a lot and i want
to pass it along people can take it or
leave it but i wanted to make it free
for everyone
so it's going to be free for everyone so
uh
this is uh as as eric erickson would say
the generative stage of life um which is
to
uh pass along the wisdom that you've had
to others
um there's something else that you
created out of
uh i guess i mean from scratch right you
weren't taking another product
uh the dot collector and i think that's
different
but related can you tell us what the dot
collector is
better than me tell you about it let me
show you the dot collector
a week after the u.s election our
research team held a meeting to discuss
what a trump presidency would mean for
the u.s economy
naturally people had different opinions
on the matter and how we were
approaching the discussion
the dot collector collects these views
it has a list of a few dozen attributes
and so whenever someone thinks something
about another person's thinking
it's easy for them to convey that
assessment
they simply note the attribute and
provide a rating from 1 to 10.
for example as the meeting began a
researcher named jen rated mia 3
in other words badly for not showing a
good balance of assertiveness and
open-mindedness
has the meeting transpired jen's
assessment so
people added up like this others in the
room had very different opinions
that's normal different people are
always going to have different opinions
and who knows who's right let's just
look at what people thought about how i
was doing
some people thought i did well others
poorly with each of these views we can
explore the thinking behind the numbers
here's what jen and larry said
note that everyone gets to express their
thinking including their critical
thinking
regardless of their position in the
company jan who's 24 years old and fresh
out of college
can tell me the ceo of the company that
i'm approaching things terribly
this tool helps people both express
their opinions
and separate themselves from their
opinions to see things from a higher
level
when jen and others shift their
attentions from
inputting their opinions to looking down
on the whole screen their perspective
changes
they see their own opinions as just one
of many
and naturally start to ask themselves
how do i know my opinion is right
that shift in perspective of going above
it
and seeing the full range of views
shifts the conversation from arguing
over individual
opinions to figuring out objective
criteria for determining which opinions
are best
behind the dot collector is a computer
that is watching what all these people
are thinking correlates it with how they
think
and communicates back to each of them
based on that
then it draws the data from the meetings
to create a pointless painting of what
people are like and how they think
and it does all that guided by
algorithms
knowing what people are like helps to
match them up better with their jobs
for example a creative thinker who is
unreliable
might be matched up with someone who is
reliable but not creative
knowing what people are like also allows
us to decide what responsibilities to
give them
and to weigh our decisions based on
people's merits
we call it their believability
here's an example of a vote that we took
where the majority of people felt one
way
but when we weighed people's views on
the basis of their merits
the answer was completely different
this process allows us to make decisions
not based on democracy and not based on
autocracy but based on algorithms that
take people's believability
into consideration notice that everybody
could speak out on
anything notice that we're constantly
getting what everybody's thinking
and and also we're learning about how
they think
both because uh we learn what they see
and how that might be different from
what others see and we also know
that there's triangulation and feedback
to other people
so take a look so if i get feedback from
say a majority or even a significant
minority of
uh say students right because i teach
and i can imagine you know all of my
undergraduates
100 plus of them doing the dot collector
during my lecture
so if i get feedback from even a
significant minority that says
you know you were tone deaf during this
part of the lecture
like you weren't listening to what
people were saying you were like talking
past us
um you said that there is a probably
like
evolutionarily programmed part of our
brain
to say ah and to you know
flee or fight uh in response to that
so tell me what you like think like
could happen with the dot collector that
doesn't make me just defensive
and and totally write off um this you
know 30
of my students say i'm arrogant in a
certain part of my lecture well first of
all
um people
analytics people you got to love this
right
i mean we're speaking to you
we're preaching to the preachers here
okay
people analytics okay now
curiosity composure
in other words okay what is what is
going on and why
and we can build that in the
into the algorithms to determine that
when you start to
enter your question why
um okay why does one have a different
view than
another and you start to form your
theories we bring
build these things into the tool for an
algorithm
that on the database you can say oh i
see
that one uh has a certain thinking
profile
that's different from this one or you
know
let me go into the database and find
those things that those people who saw
it that way have in common
so the analytical work can be done
behind the scenes as you're seeing
okay these people saw it or who are
friends and who are
do they work together do they see things
so you've got
all of that data that you don't even
have to analyze because the thing about
analyzing data is that i found out from
both the investment analysis and the
people analysis
is that if you observe how you are
analyzing it
you can program the computer to do that
for you
and so now invariably it's better than
you um idiosyncratically occasionally
doing what you think you should do well
yeah i think danny kahneman would say
that you're
um and you could do it in a triangulated
way so think about how much fun that is
people and a lot of people so uh if you
if you say okay now here's the data how
do we find out
use that data realizing that's just one
day
so one day okay it could be this reason
but
do it two days do it three days see the
pattern over time
okay and then just intellectually
analytically
having the fun of saying okay how would
we test the why
behind that right like you could have a
hypothesis
like oh maybe when i said where i went
to school
for college maybe my students heard that
as condescending
that's a hypothesis i can test that
hypothesis the next day
over time yeah so the collection of the
data when i say
a dot collector it's for the connecting
of dots
right in other words a lot of people
don't do a good job of connecting dots
it's like annual so the dots are
observations but we don't connect them
right we don't actually see the pattern
we don't
deduce like what the cause is we just
experience like one dot after the other
that's right and i think like
annual reviews these are daily 360
reviews
right because um annual reviews
are ridiculous they are ridiculous i
totally agree with you
there there's no you know in the
intervening period like there's no
adequate feedback
the thing that everybody wants most for
their development and also
to make sure the system is fair is
ongoing feedback
right okay so it provides ongoing
feedback on a daily basis
so whoever i'm working whoever i'm
working for or these others i get a 360
review
so at the end of the day everybody looks
back at their 360 review then they can
discuss it
they can explore it and it's on a daily
basis rather than something like
um uh an annual review and you sit there
and you remember and you don't remember
and it's all of these things
you know i mean that's terrible so
that's why i did the dot collector
hey ray hey angela that was an
interesting conversation thoroughly
enjoyed it um angela
do you think we should dot ray all right
let me let me pull up the dot collector
here i have two dots for you
uh the first one is uh i gave you
a nine uh for being open-minded uh i
think
given you know the decades of your
career and how strongly you believe in
an idea meritocracy
uh it would be very easy for you to just
be preaching about why that is the way
we should all live and
i saw you playing with ideas exploring i
thought that was
really impressive uh how much humility
you bring to this topic
so what thought did i get my prediction
is that ray wants a critical dot because
experts
that's exactly right right i mean like
what could i have done better
okay so i'm gonna give you a four for
practical
oh tell me why
uh i thought there were a few places
where i wanted more concreteness and
more detail about the how
especially if i don't work in a culture
like bridgewaters where people are you
know constantly used to to getting this
kind of feedback
i wanted to know okay what do you say to
yourself when uh let's talk about right
now actually i just gave you a score
that's why that's just why it's so great
right
because you you brought it up and now we
can talk about it
and i didn't know that i'm great now i
know that let's talk about it
good okay so i just gave you a four on
practicality
how do you react to that you almost look
like you enjoy it well i'm curious i
wanna
yeah in other words you have a need that
i'm not fulfilling
and so you've just told me in a sense
that you know you want to take a look at
it so explain more how can i
wha what what what are your questions
what can i do
okay so i guess the first thing i want
to know is when you get that four
uh it's obviously not the ten you're
aiming for uh what are the thoughts and
emotions that go through your head that
is exactly what i wanted to do
i mean you sounded enthusiastic curious
and even excited but of course
wait wait wait wait how where is the
defensiveness where's the
hold on practical i just said we created
principles you and dot collector like
are are you really not defensive
so it's so shot it's so shocking that it
just so you understand
it's so shocking that you would ask that
question
okay you seem to be shocked at my
reaction
why let me ask you why i think the why
for me
like if adam says angela i give you a
nine on openness or open-mindedness
i feel great and then i'm smiling and
then i want to hear more about why
adam thinks i'm so great if adam thinks
i'm a four
on practical i feel like i
failed in a way and i
just mostly spend my energy wanting to
change the four into a nine
okay can i share why you
well i think that's so illogical and
tragic
almost yes please okay
first um you're um you're assuming
are you assuming he's right or are you
assuming he's wrong you don't
understand anything it seems like you're
so
susceptible to his approval
without even understanding why and that
people could walk up to you and they say
um something's going wrong between me
and adam here in other words
so we gotta get in sync if we're gonna
have a relationship so i need to
understand that
and then also there might be the
possibility
that i could have done something better
and so how are you going to grow if you
don't hear this
it's all rational i think one thing that
might be helpful for me
to be more excited when someone gives me
negative feedback or you know whatever
like constructive criticism
is that if i think about the future not
the past if adam says
four and i'm just looking backward i'm
like [ __ ]
four like that's not very good there's
like
yeah but but andrew if i look forward
and i think like oh
four okay great thing it's my three
things let me just
ask you like um
you know kind of again do you think it's
right
i mean you haven't even heard what it is
or why it is
and you're saying oh it's uncomfortable
okay so is that is is that you don't
even know what it is
and you don't want it yeah interestingly
yeah i'm not even thinking i think when
you're like do i think it's right and
i'm like thinking i was mostly feeling
right there
okay okay so i i'm just trying to say
it's like sure
that's feedback right it's like it's
like sugar
okay what i mean like let's just decide
what's good for us okay
and just try to say that accuracy is
good for us
information is good for us right
accuracy knowing more
versus feeling less right and if we are
like we are
it's great it's okay we are like we are
now how do we want to deal with that in
the best possible way
and who can we work with who complements
the way we work
so that they can help us and we can help
them like
you really can help me and us
be able to communicate this to people
because
you are living it okay that's great but
we should
intellectually we have to agree is
accuracy is good
and knowing that the imp impacts that
you're having on other people or how to
improve
is is progress i agree i
i guess that leads me to a follow-up
question which is ray it's easy to see
how the dot collector is useful for
somebody who processes
feedback the way you do if somebody
takes it more defensively like angela
was describing her younger self
we were wondering we've talked about
this for years actually
is it helpful to shift and not rate the
person but rate the performance or the
behavior
i don't care what you i don't care what
you call it
just as long as we get okay ray
i mean just just feel good about saying
it i think you have to help
people intellectually
want it it's like do i want the coaching
if i was on a team and the coach
said you're not making the
moves correctly or something you know
or whatever you're not big enough to
play that position
okay but you could be good at this other
position
okay it's it's like first let's start
there
then what's experienced because i've
done this with
literally thousands of people because
bridgewater locates thousands of people
then you take that and you say okay how
do i go on that journey
like angela would be ready for the
journey
but um i think the the the the point
that this actually also
i i think that helps us make is that dot
collector is great principles u is great
but
their tools they have to be embedded in
a culture of
trust and uh you know
growth right because you can't drop
these tools into a culture where
people don't really actually have a
fundamental level of trust
with each other or have an orientation
to improving themselves right and i
think that's important
well the trust the trust comes from
truthfulness in other words okay i know
and caring asking for this and a motive
that like i'm
giving you we have to start but we have
to start
let's say if i was going to coach you in
doing this
we would have to start and i would say
okay so
just analytically what's happening you
have an emotional self
and you have an intellectual self and
right now they're at odds
your emotional self is on is is on fire
but your intellectual self says that's
right
right and one of the great ways of
success
is when you are align your subliminal
emotional
thoughts with your intellectual thoughts
because when they line up
then you're probably making a good
decision
so the capacity to look at yourself
because a lot of things subliminally
come up that are great and
they could be terrible too they have to
be looked at let's in
inspiration you know intuition
it all comes from the subliminals self
and it comes up
maybe it's right and maybe it's not
right and then you have your
intellectual
okay and if you can align these two and
say
okay they're in alignment and and if you
align them with each other and then you
align them with
other people you're probably right right
but if they're out of alignment like
in your case it sounds like they're out
of alignment or you would think
to me it's i'm just trying to get them
in alignment i think alignment is
actually a secret to everything
that was fun that was fun um okay i have
some questions for you
and here's the first one you ready okay
all right
um thinking about principles you one of
our attendees
asked were there any decisive career
shifts
by people who took principles you the
assessment
well principles u is um uh you know
um new we're just now launching it and
it's been well tested so
i don't have the track record of that
but i can say
for having 20 years or so of all the
different types of tests that
um there was big direction changes i
think you all probably know about that
when there was genuine personal
discovery
of what somebody's like and what the
great
fit is so i think that's that's the
discovery right
what am i like and what is the great fit
for me
not only in terms of the career but also
the people that i'm with
and so that's happened a lot it happened
to me by the way i
i discovered a few years ago that i have
many strengths but
one that i don't want to develop is
becoming a better manager and leader
note to self and shift as well um
okay uh second question does the
delivery of radical
transparency matter uh and i know you
think it does
so the question continues how do you ray
recommend crafting an environment
for optimal success of the delivery of
feedback
well i think you start off with like in
any good relationship like how do i want
to be with
each other should i tell you should you
not tell me
um how do we want to be with each other
and then also recognize prepare them
uh with the alignment issue that we were
talking about
your emotional self is going to be one
way your uh
intellectual self is going to be the
other way it's going to go this way
you will experience it look at yourself
what do you want to do almost everybody
wants to do that
wants to get the right answer wants to
get a truth wants to get in sync
they just have to guide themselves some
can do it and some
can't sometimes they find no i just
can't bring myself
but you have to always if there's a
conflict in any way or any disagreement
and something's not going wrong
pause and go above it and say
how are we going to be with each other
how should we be
and that makes that contract so you can
go back into it
and then sometimes you have to remind
people what you're doing
that we're trying what do you want you
know you say what do you want me to do
do you want me to tell you do you not
want me to tell you
how should i handle that and you can ask
permission
you could also put it in context you
know i really enjoy
this this and the other thing about you
but let's look at this thing
i think that's good but i like the idea
of asking for advice because sometimes
if someone said
hey would you like some critical
feedback right now i think often i would
say
yeah i can and then some days i'm like
no i don't want any critical feedback
and that's okay and that's okay i love
that advice thank you that's not
intuitive
all right and also uh to communicate in
the way that's comfortable to
communicate
like sometimes we find out maybe
somebody doesn't want to do it fast on
the spot or they maybe they don't want
to do it right at that what about in
front of us or maybe they want to type
it into an
email and make it a calm thoughtful
exchange however they want to
communicate is effective
you know it's an adage that we should uh
praise
publicly and blame privately um i wonder
if you would agree
with that or not no i mean i think you
have to reach an agreement with the
people but
it almost says that um mistakes or
weaknesses or
um are bad like you've got to hide them
right okay like let's go up into this
corner so i can give you some critical
feedback
i mean inadvertently sends a message
that that's oh it's a terrible thing
if we can start to appreciate that
accuracy is the important thing i think
the educational system
makes a mess of these things you know
you grow up and you're not allowed to
make mistakes you're a star
if you don't make mistakes i mean the
world doesn't work that way
or what you're not supposed to have any
weaknesses let's
recognize that everybody makes mistakes
everybody has weaknesses
and that's okay so let's not go hide
that let's not go hide the transparency
if you can get over it sometimes you
need an adjustment
into that you know there's a process
that we go through
you know we call it getting to the other
side getting to the other side means you
have that one state of mind and then you
take a little practice and so on and you
can get there so that we can talk about
those things
ideally uh one of the attendees asked
for those interested in taking this test
and i think this must be her or him
uh can we find it online somewhere
yep it's gonna be um all over the place
we're just
about to launch it right now i hope that
you will
take it i hope that you'll pass it to
people you have relationships and look
at how it
how your relationships are described and
provide us with lots of feedback
particularly you guys give us lots of
feedback especially critical
compliments don't do you any good well
they can do a little bit of good but
i but we we agree
you